bon je vais t'expliquer ton futur mon oh
oui expliquez-moi et bien voilà
écoute-moi
bien je te raconterai
simplement tout ce que l'on fait pour
chercher à leur plaire un air
désarmant un sourire charmant ça
évidemment je crois pouvoir le
faire il faut même séduire les les
Allemands bien qu'il soi toujours nos
ennemis
extrêm les vieuxig j' aller quand
même il a des
millions tu
l'aimesi comme il faut m'abiller et me
maquiller ça ça dépend des
heures pour le thé le goûter discrétion
tout dans l'intention la flamme
intérieure mais pour les grands soup
Maxim alors sois sublime que les mâles
en Meur les bijoux les fourrures et
Paris à pied il y
a
métier tu vois bien c'est tout
simplement qu'on peut conquérir en
entier le demi
un air
désarmant un sourire charmant un peu de
mystèremi un peu comme la Joconde
exactement c'est une
vocation n'est-ce pas c'est une
profession aux avantages extrêmes on la
f parfois mais on y revient quand
même c'est plus fort que nous
en
ma noiselle cette
[Musique]
Val oui benéict vra un sourire voilà un
désarmant je vais conquérir
le